now inflation is at nine percent as we
were just uh discussing with our
previous uh guests it's a 40-year high
and of course that is putting some real
pressure on family budgets labor says
that thank you to that rising inflation
the average family is almost 500 pounds
worse off since the chancellor's spring
statement so what do they intend to do
about it let's try and find out we're
joined now by the shadow chief secretary
to the treasury of pat mcfadden thank
you very much for being with us uh this
morning um so let's just start off with
that research shall we you've been
looking at the impact of inflation on
families and how concerned are you
well we're very concerned this is the
biggest issue facing people right now
it's driven
in large part by the increase in energy
bills which is really driving inflation
up but we've also got inflation across
the board on food bills uh other cost
costs for industry and so on
and it's really really tough for
families out there now and people are
having to make some very very difficult
choices so what would labor do to tackle
inflation
well you need a short-term plan and a
long-term plan and in the short term
we've got to get help to people
particularly with energy bills so we've
advocated
this policy of a windfall levy on the
excess profits of the oil and gas
companies who are making the most out of
the current energy price inflation
and together with other measures using
that to get more help
to people with energy bills
particularly those
at the lower end of the income scale who
spend a greater proportion of their
income on energy than better off
families and what's a long-term plan the
long-term plan is we've got to improve
the country's economic growth record
we're in this spiral of
difficult choices around tax and spend
because we've had poor economic growth
for 10 or 12 years now so we've got to
get our growth record up in the future
in order to make the country more
prosperous and the people living in it
more prosperous let me explain that what
that means how how do you do that i mean
like
better growth is sounds great doesn't it
i think everyone would agree with that
but but how do you do well you need you
need a number of things uh first of all
we've got to you were talking to nadeem
zahari about skill levels for example
we've still got 200 000 children
living in areas where there are no good
or outstanding schools the government's
actually having a debate with themselves
about sending not enough people i guess
too many people to university at the
same time
the question was how would labour tackle
inflation the windfall tax obviously is
something that we've talked about uh
every interview i talk about labour
front benches it's windfall tax but then
leaping towards schools as a way of
tackling inflation so it's not about
inflation it's a contributor to
long-term growth the skills of your
people also for example the green
transition that we've got to make
that can be a contributor to
long-term economic growth if we get it
right we match the technology the
capacity to make things here you need a
short-term plan at the moment to help
people with a cost of living crisis and
you need a long-term plan geared at the
country's prosperity um i guess i'm um
you know trying to work out a bit more
about the policy platform that labour
has i understand the windfall tax and
it's something that clearly you know you
can see government thinking about as
well um but it does feel like every time
i talk to labour all you talk about is
the windfall tax and the crisis is is
real as you say you know inflation at a
40-year high you want an emergency
budget you need something else in it
other than
let me give you another example if you
take costs for business which are a real
part of this right now we've advocated
more help for business rate relief paid
for by increasing the digital services
tax for this year
in order to get business rate relief to
a greater range of businesses that could
take
up to 5 700 pounds of business rate
bills for some small and medium-sized
businesses because inflation yes it's
about consumers but it's also about cost
for business too so that's another plank
of our policy platform alongside the
windfall levy um just talking about um
how you pay for the policy platform as
well so the windfall tax rate is around
two billion pounds a year on the sort of
latest figures you also want to you know
spend 28 billion pounds a year on the
sort of green plans tackling climate
change you want to increase defense
spending you know you've spoken out
against the rise of national insurance
how are you going to pay for all this
would labour be putting it up borrowing
well let me take the green plan that you
just quoted look at the scale of what
we've got to do over the next 10 or 20
years there are 30 million cars on the
road but i'm not asking about the right
or wrong of the policy i'm asking about
how it'll be paid for it will be paid
for by more borrowing wouldn't it uh
that that is a borrowing plan it's
borrowing for investment and the
government's already doing it at a time
of rising inflatable interest rates
the government has already issued 16
billion pounds of green gilts for
precisely this purpose uh governments in
poland germany france all issuing green
gills that is our policy to
borrow in the markets to invest in this
transition and if we don't do that if we
abandoned green gilts for example so
we're not going to do any of that what
we'd be doing is leaving greater cost
for the next generation because the
longer you leave this transition the
more expensive it will be and also it
will be unfair to consumers if you take
these heat pumps right now for example
cost a lot more than a gas boiler for my
consumer for my constituents
this transition has to be fair it can't
just be a transition for the rich so
this requires a partnership between
government and industry to make sure
that britain make gets the best
advantage out of it and also to make
sure it's done in a fair way if you
model the cost of the rising interest
rates on this
look we always have an eye on everything
but green guilts are already part of the
policy mix we want to use them to make
sure we get this transition done in a
fair way okay okay um now i just want to
have a look at a piece that you wrote
for the times uh back in march 2020. now
this was at the time of the leadership
contest uh to replace jeremy corbyn and
this is what you said if it's quote
uh okay that is not the quote
i was hoping for so the quote said after
labour lost its third election in a row
in 1987 neil kinnick launched a no holds
barred policy review in which everything
was on the table including the sacred
cows such as support for unilateral
nuclear disarmament he did that because
he knew that fundamental change was
necessary if labour was to win again and
then he went on to say after a
shattering defeat the key question is
direction it means having a policy
platform that looks to the future
i just wonder if you feel like that you
know genuine no holds barred policy
review has happened under kirstalma
well i've always been clear that
leadership wasn't just about a change of
personnel it had to be a change of
direction to
when you lost
four elections in a row
uh you can't just go back with the same
policy platform and
a person in a different suit and expect
the electorate to
uh to take a different attitude so i'm
very much in favor of root and branch
examination of things but if you take
the greek and that's happened if you
change to take the example we've been
discussing this morning on the green
agenda there i think you've got an
ambitious program
for a transition that's going to happen
anyway but i want us to be hungry for
change in every area in education policy
in health policy learning the lessons of
the covert experience what can we do
better in the future being
we will only know the answer to that
when we come to the next election but i
think there is a hunger for change in
the labour party now it feels like you'd
like to go a bit further
we've always got further to go because
when you've had such an emphatic defeat
as the one that we had in 2019
the worst thing you could do is to think
one more heave was going to do it for
you one more heave won't do it for us
we've got a new leader but we also need
a new direction too interesting and you
don't think that new direction has come
yet well we're it's a we're part of the
way through and we've got you know some
time to go before the next election but
i'm confident that we'll have an
exciting and responsible programme when
it comes to that
um we spoke uh to nadim zahawi uh
earlier about the meeting between
seagray and boris johnson he couldn't
tell us who called that meeting
are you concerned about the fact that
sue grey the civil servant leading the
investigation into particular met with
the prime minister
i've got every faith in sugray's
integrity she is a civil servant of the
highest integrity we don't know the
details of that meeting
it's not clear who called it there's
different accounts of that so it's hard
for me to say what was said there um but
i do have faith in her integrity and
let's see what she says when the report
comes out
okay i mean does feel after the met have
concluded their investigation no more
fines for boris johnson that actually
the person who's come out of this with
their future more uncertain is actually
kiss dama because he said of course that
he will resign if he's found to breach
the law with the investigation that's
going on by uh durham police
given the unpredictability of these
fines was that gamble really such a
great idea
look i think the statement he made the
other week
showed real integrity and leadership
he's the former director of public
prosecutions he takes adherence to the
law extremely seriously
and if you contrast that to the culture
that's been exposed both by what the
mets uncovered and by what we're likely
to see in sue gray's uh report you see
that culture comes from the top isn't
this almost
you know the point
why is kirsten put his future on the
line in a way that he perhaps didn't
need to kirsten uh holds public service
and the standards of public service
extremely highly uh you know he doesn't
believe this notion that well they're
all the same no scandal matters no shame
matters you can get away with anything
there's a real contrast in standards
between what he said and the way he's
conducted himself through this remember
he also this is someone who isolated
four or five times i think when having
covered our family members have he's
taken adherence to the rules extremely
seriously okay and he's contrasting that
with a culture that's been exposed in
number 10.
okay um it it feels like it has sparked
a bit of an informal leadership contest
though doesn't it um you know we've got
pages like the front financial times
doing interviews with uh word streeting
framing them about whether or not he's
the savior of the labour party uh is
where street in the savior labour
desperately needs lisa nandy and bridget
phillips haven't rolled ruled out a run
when they're done interviews i mean this
is not helpful is it
well look uh i'm very confident in
kyocera's leadership but it's also
really encouraging for me to see so many
other talented people in the labour
party their time is not yet maybe it
will be one day in the future okay thank
you uh very much uh pat mcfadden there
from the labour party